i'm dave rubin and it's time for another
reuben report friday panel extravaganza
we'll be focusing on burning books and
mashing potato heads today
and joining me are author and journalist
nancy rommelman
host of the book club at prageru and
author of the
upcoming book speechless michael knowles
and author of the
occasionally banned book irreversible
damage
abigail schreier guys welcome to the
reuben report
great to be with you dave thanks for
having us all right thank you
michael and abigail i've had you guys on
the show before so i want to just
kick this off quickly with uh with nancy
just so she can intro herself
to the good people if they don't know
her nancy can you give me a life recap
in
45 seconds 45 seconds i am a journalist
and an author
this trend of people getting rid of
things they don't like or don't
understand sort of by
mobbing uh happened to me a couple of
years ago when i had a podcast that uh
some employees of my my husband's former
business didn't like and they decided to
sort of cancel him and me
weren't able to cancel me i've been
reporting all summer for reason magazine
on the protests in portland
uh that's been sort of unpopular too to
talk about what's actually happening as
opposed to what people want to
believe to be happening so i'm sort of
always very popular i think that kind of
sums it up
and you had an incredible prageru video
about what happened to you what's it
called
not how to be brave it's uh how to be a
dangerous person and what's interesting
is like i had
i really had never interfaced with
prager at all um not exactly
like the same politics so much they were
the nicest people
they were so understanding and their
fans man
were amazing and still write to me so
i was happy to be there i thought they
did a great job trying to tell the story
so i think that's a funny thing for
people like abigail for people like you
for people like me
that somehow you start talking about
free speech next thing you know all
those crazy right-wing maniacs like
michael knowles and dennis prager
are saying hey you want to come over and
talk to me and then they don't hurt you
and they don't poison you
it's very bizarre but look this this has
obviously been like a particularly crazy
week it seems like every week is nuts
but the dr seuss this thing this week
where the
the publisher announced they're no
longer going to publish six of the books
and that's their right to do as a
private company obviously but then
suddenly places like ebay
are saying they're not going to carry
the books anymore and now libraries are
having very important
meetings to decide whether they can have
the books in stock
you know in the libraries or not it
seems like the crazy is just getting
ramped up
and ramped up so first i guess my first
question would be this
as all of you have dealt with some
version of cancel culture in your own
lives and professional careers
are we even close to the end or is this
just
are we just still like smack dab in the
middle of it abigail your
your book got temporarily banned from
target and then
you were back on are you on today have
you checked this morning i'm back off
they deleted it oh yeah after there was
public
outcry in response to public outcry they
put it back on and then they quietly
deleted it again
so we are let me tell you they're just
getting started
um and and frankly all the publishers
everybody's dependent on amazon you're
talking about a company
it's not just a private company a
company that controls over 80
of the marketplace for books so you know
they do what they like
and they can make books disappear and
that's what they're doing
so wait you were you were kicked off
target because like one person was upset
then there was an outcry to the outcry
so you got back on but are you saying
you're not in target now or you're not
on amazon
it's gone my book is gone from
target.com even though it was selling
very well
but you still are on amazon at least at
the moment for the moment
yes for the moment i'm on amazon knowles
you wrote a book with no words
your upcoming book speechless is gonna
have a few more words i presume i don't
have the advanced copy yet but
uh you're the type of guy that it would
be very easy for them to just
take out you've you've said scary things
in your day
and i say very scary things in my new
book so i actually have been telling
people on my show
i i hope that you pre-order the book i
won't be surprised if the book is then
taken off i hope
i hope that it will be available
somewhere else but
i i do think that the book is scary to
them because
one thing that conservatives have been
pointing out is they're
they're getting rid of dr seuss right
ebay is clamping down on dr seuss stock
they won't even
publish certain dr seuss books but they
allow mineconf
to be sold on amazon they allow mineconf
to be sold on ebay
so what's the deal with that and the
deal with that is that dr seuss is
actually a far greater threat to the
liberal establishment
than mein kampf is nobody takes mein
kampf seriously
and the left calls all of us nazis
anyway so the only way that that column
is going to have any effect
is if people know what nazis are if they
keep nazis top of mind
but people like dr seuss people like
abigail who writes a perfectly
mainstream
uh scholarly book people like ryan t
anderson
who wrote the wonderfully titled when
harry became sally
another scholarly work on the
transgender moment that actually is
on right now for the record and now now
that's been kicked off amazon that
really is a threat to the dominant
liberal regime because
they don't have any answer for the
arguments that abigail or ryan have made
in those books
so the only thing that they can do is
kick it off
and and i i don't think it's getting any
better because i don't think
that we're fighting it in anywhere near
the right way if anything i think that
conservatives and libertarians are
basically playing into their hands
yeah well by the way when all this
craziness happened this week i went into
the garage and i found my copy
of the places you'll go which pretty
much everyone gets when they graduate
uh college and if you read this book
this
knowles is the true threat to the
establishment because you know what this
book is about
individual responsibility that you might
be able to accomplish something for
yourself
in your life and the government doesn't
have to do it before you it it's wild
uh but nancy you've as you led as you
said before you've sort of lived through
the mob attacking you uh and and
survived and then you find some strange
bridges to build maybe in places you
didn't think um
do you think we're still in right in the
center of this thing
i'm not sure first of all i mean i'm
obviously against
banning everything and i think the
impulse comes from people who don't
they don't trust other people to make
decisions for themselves so they don't
trust themselves to make decisions for
themselves so they're like well i'm
gonna i'm gonna hand that over to
whether it's you know
amazon or the government or the new york
times or whatever but i've been
reporting a lot for the past three weeks
on the whole
donald mcneil situation at the new york
times and how he was sort of like
shuffled out the door by a more you know
angry activist contingent that doesn't
want certain words said they do not want
certain ideas explored
and i mean i see it as ambition
disguised as you know do goodism
but here's a question for you guys and
it has to do with amazon or the new york
times
sure okay someone's book is making a lot
of money
the dr seuss books or abigail's books
potentially
and they're like well no we got to go
along with the crowd we got to get rid
of it
but you know what what if their bottom
line starts to suffer and they see
someone going and buying
abigail's book someplace else and
they're like huh we just lost 800 000
what happens at the new york times when
they stop running they really still do
incredible journalism but when they
really can't do that anymore because the
people in the building are upset
what happens when their bottom line
starts to drop
you know i don't actually think that's
uh that will work at all because
you're talking about companies with
monopolistic power amazon's monopoly is
so complete
that they have over they control over 80
percent of books bought and sold in the
us including secondary markets
by the way of used books they were all
deleted for ryan's book what that means
is that no book that has a heterodox
idea in it
will now get published okay wherever
there or will be
why would a publisher ever take a chance
on a book that can be
vaporized tomorrow by amazon they won't
the effects on free speech
are profound look i mean wells fargo
should wells fargo be able to ban you
from getting a mortgage because you have
a hillary sign on your front lawn
well they control far less of the market
for mortgages and private loans than
amazon does for books
this is a big big deal you can't just go
to other places
publishers will not take you if amazon
won't distribute your products
i actually think there's almost
something more perverse than that it's
it's that they actually now care about
social justice or whatever you wanna
call it more than they care about their
bottom line i actually think
in many cases those people that were
protesting at the new york times you
know the people that in effect
got rid of barry weiss and that now have
created this new situation
that they would gladly destroy their own
businesses it's sort of like with the
nba
players destroying their we know what's
happening to nba ratings the more they
talk about social justice
to the point that the nba put black
lives matter on the court thinking it
was a good idea then they saw the
ratings drop
and now they got rid of it i mean did
they solve racism i guess not but i
think they will all gladly
destroy their own properties knowles
what do you think about that this
this is such a good point dave i think
the the
you've really hit on what they're doing
here and why we
as conservatives as libertarians as
classical liberals why we've been so
ineffective
we have bought the the lie that
political correctness or wokism or
leftism whatever you want to call it
has laid for us what political
correctness is
is a way to destroy all the old
standards right
i'm actually willing to say this i think
the left understands free speech
much better than conservatives and
libertarians do i think what the left
says herbert marcus wrote this famously
in an infamous essay called repressive
tolerance
where he basically said we can't
tolerate intolerant people so you got to
shut up the conservatives and encourage
the leftists
but it's not just marcusa john locke
said this john locke in the letter
concerning toleration said
was the father of liberalism and the
most famous letter on toleration he says
we got to tolerate everybody except for
atheists we can't tolerate them at all
uh john milton ariopogitica most famous
essay or speech i suppose
on on free speech in english language he
says we gotta tolerate everybody and
have all free
speech except for catholics and the
thing is they were sort of right at the
time given the political circumstances
the what the reality that the left
understands is that all speech regimes
have some limits
in the united states from the very
beginning of our country we have
outlawed whole swaths of speech
fraud sedition fighting words threats
all these sorts of things right and none
of us really contests that obscenity
which was enforced until very very
recently and sometimes still is
and and what the left did is they saw
that this wonderful american free speech
tradition that allows
so much speech so much more than so many
other other traditions
and they said okay there are some
exceptions here there are some
boundaries we're just going to transform
those boundaries and have them work for
us
such that in the 1940s and 50s if you
published communist subversive material
to overthrow the government that would
be banned i think it's perfectly
understandable that that would be banned
today forget about the communist
material you publish dr
seuss that's what's going to be banned
so i think while we need to defend free
speech in the abstract i totally agree
with that
what we also need to do is defend the
particular speech
that is being banned right now because
what i think the left is doing is just
totally shifting the standards to uproot
our entire american speech tradition
so with that in mind go ahead abigail i
was just going to say i
i think it's important to note that that
this really isn't a right left issue
to the extent that anybody who has ever
had a heterodox idea
can be banned right now and everyone
who's ever been wanted to be exposed i
mean there are a lot of reasons to want
to read
dr seuss including just or huck finn
including just to understand what the
world was like
then you don't need to agree with the
agree with a book to read it
you just have to have an open mind and a
curious mind
and they are your ideas are being banned
right now you can't get you won't be
able to get access to them
amazon is quietly shutting them down in
addition to controlling all the web
services
i mean they got rid of parlor for that
reason the vulnerability and the
chilling effect of
free speech that amazon can have is
profound
i don't unders i don't sorry i don't
understand why they don't want to allow
history to exist
okay let's say you're skiing and you do
really something really stupid on the
ski slope and you
you fly off and you hit your head well
you know the next time you go skiing
you're going to say you know maybe i'm
not going to do that that wasn't a
great idea i mean what do they say about
the holocaust never forget
right never forget do not scrub
over history it's a bad idea i mean we
all know like you know let the bad ideas
lose let the good ideas win
um i know i'm i'm the continual optimist
but
as we were talking before we went on yes
things are pretty
awful with you know amazon scrubbing
things and with not being able to get
ideas across i still believe that people
are going to create
new ways for us to tell stories and
we've we've seen
um dave do this and we've seen this on
other platforms they are they don't have
hegemony now
and we may feel sort of you know
constricted by what's going on now
but i just think if you keep keep keep
insisting on putting good work into the
world
it will reach where it wants to go yeah
well you guys know my feelings on that
like human ingenuity is always the one
thing that will save us and that's also
why i've kind of been against regulation
because to me if you regulate these
things
you just calcify them forever but
michael can you address nancy's point
there because we did
the prageru book club we did 1984
together
and what she's talking about there is
the memory hole why do they
actually memory whole things and i think
there there is a specific reason for it
well because if you control the past you
control the future that's the first part
of it
and it goes so much deeper i notice the
left always gets very angry when the
right invokes
1984 and they'll say well george orwell
was a democratic socialist which is
sort of true but also george orwell's
definition of that was very different
than we might define it as now
but the parallels are so striking the
erasure of history orwell writes at
length about that process
a new speak which we might call
political correctness this total
changing of the language
to change our minds and then most
notably and i think this actually ties
in especially to
what abigail writes about is double
think
orwell writes that the big brother
regime relies
perhaps most of all on doublethink this
idea
that the citizens need to hold
contradictory ideas in their head
at the same time because if you have to
hold those contradictory ideas
you you totally lose your ability and
your willingness
to reason and to fight back and so this
is why i think
that the left is pushing uh feminism on
the one hand and transgenderism on the
other those two ideas obviously undercut
one another
but it doesn't really matter because the
the point of this entire regime is not
to
put forth a substantive positive
left-wing vision
it's just to destroy all the old history
all the old standards
all the old ideas and all our old way of
life so so abigail do you think that
even though your book obviously did
incredibly well despite
dealing with some of this censorship
stuff do you think that that
complicates a publishing house from
picking you up for the next book because
it's just like these ideas are in the
system now
you know they tried to i had jordan's
book on my table right before we started
but
they tried to stop jordan peterson's
newest book which came out this week
even though
12 rules for life sold something like
six million copies and basically kept
everyone at penguin random house which
is my publisher by the way
it kept pretty much everyone there
employed and they tried to stop you know
some employees
tried to stop the second book um
i think i think that they are absolutely
they don't care
about how well a book is selling because
my book sold incredibly well i mean i've
got
24 over 2 400 reviews of my book on
amazon
people love the book but they can't they
won't be able to get it if amazon
disappears it
and anybody who is you know every
publisher is subject to amazon
it's a big deal and we're going to see
people you know
not expressing themselves if youtube
could drop them
not interviewing people that youtube
might just if you
might disappear their channel i mean
this is you know the
the effects are profound and we're all
reliant on these big techs i mean they
are dominant utilities
and they're shutting off the power so
nancy you want people to be dangerous
what what can they do what
forget forget us forget somewhat public
people that are that are public you know
that are authors and and youtubers and
the rest of it
what can the average guy do that owns a
shop or owns a coffee shop whatever it
might be
uh think for themselves oh but besides
that uh i will say you know
having covered um the protests in
portland and if you guys read reason
magazine i got a big piece on the may
issue
these are people there i mean it's a
very small portion of the population but
just like you know the the arguments
that people have online that we're
trying to push against
they seem to control the narrative but
in my experience
they're super super super good at
tearing things down
and destroying things but they're not
good
yet as far as i can see on building
anything and i wonder if you guys think
that i mean i i see that you know if if
the people in portland get their way
they're just going to continue to
cannibalize each other because that's
what they know how to do
it's going to be the same at the new
york times if you've become super super
good at like
sharpening your knife and ah i can get
rid of barry weiss or i can get rid of
you know james bennett okay you get rid
of these people well now you're a knife
sharpener
you're going to use your knife right so
you're going to start cannibalizing each
other
um and then i think new things get built
i mean that's what i hope i mean i hope
people can stay
you know independent and also when
someone comes at you and says something
to you like
you're a racist you know what i'm not
and i'm just not gonna play that game
with you i'm just not gonna do it
period yeah i totally agree with that i
mean i would just say that i think
things will get well
you know dave you're obviously doing a
great thing with locals
um and and things are getting built the
problem is i just don't want to live in
an america where people can't talk to
each other
when people can't explore ideas because
they're so afraid that they'll lose
their business over it and that's where
we are
i just fear though don't you think the
issue is
is even more fundamental i hate to be
the pessimist on the panel here but i
i think i'll live up to my reputation
i'll i will be the knuckle dragon
conservative here it seems to me that
what's at the heart of a lot of this
is we can't talk to one another one
because these big tech companies which
now control the public square
which they in many ways uh attained
through fraud
which william barr used to talk about
when he was attorney general and some of
the doj had been looking into but
let's assume that's going to be in the
courts for years and years and years
part of it is this technical problem
that big tech shuts us up
and therefore in a republic where
politics is speech the way we govern
ourselves is by talking to one another
and persuading one another therefore
they have all this political power
but the other problem is we don't speak
the same language
the the issue of political correctness
and wokism is they totally changed the
language i can no longer pronounce the
word
woman or latino because there are all
these sorts of consonants in there now
that i don't even know how to pronounce
and this this gets to the transgender
issue if i'm having a conversation with
somebody and i refer to caitlyn jenner
as
he and my friend refers to caitlyn
jenner as she
we are speaking different languages we
have fundamentally
different views of the world we we are i
don't even know how we can
communicate anymore because if symbols
don't refer
to objective reality if we're
undermining objective reality itself
if we can't say this is good and this is
bad and this is right and this is wrong
there's no way to communicate and so of
course they're going to control the
language and frankly
i think that was the plan all along i
have to i have to kick that to abigail
because i was about a year ago
i think maybe i told you this when when
i interviewed
interviewed you abigail i was at a
dinner with a friend of mine who's
or i think we're friends still i'm not
exactly sure but who's a bit you know
lefty lefty okay
and we got into the thing about the
trans issue and all i
said all i said which is what i always
say i want these people to be treated
with respect equality under the law i
hope they find someone that loves them
they as adults they should be allowed to
identify however they want transition
whatever they want to do
all i said is there's a biological
difference between men and women and we
should male and female and we should
just be able to
acknowledge that and and it just
derailed from there
you know and and to the point where
we're about 10 minutes in he said you
don't understand quantum physics
and i said i said you're not i said
you're right
i don't think you do either but i think
that gets to knowles's point about the
we're not even speaking remotely the
same
language and i think you've had to deal
with this quite often in the last year
that's right there are a lot of lies
being told right now i mean i totally
agree with nancy like if
you look at you know people ask me
aren't you afraid of being called the
transphobe and i just say well i'm not
i mean not only do i fully support
rights for transgender people i have a
lot of transgender friends i mean i
this is not i have i fully support not
only rights but transit the ability to
transition from mature adults
um this is just game playing look
jezebel ran an article yesterday in
which they covered
the um biologically male um runner
who is now um being recruited by all the
top schools as a
as a female okay in he will take some
girls spot
at a top college as a runner this was a
middling runner on the boys team
okay and they talked about him they said
as a young girl
andreya yearwood always dreamed of being
a runner but of course he was never a
young girl
he transitioned after middle school they
just lie
they just make stuff up so that we can't
have a conversation
and someone reading the article might
genuinely have thought
he was a young girl at some point which
he never was
so so uh nancy since you mentioned the
new york times before i mean i think
they've been basically the almost the
prime purveyor of all of this nonsense
and that type of line is exactly what we
get in the new york times
um what what do we do for the people
that only read that stuff i mean
you know i can't send them knolls videos
they're not going to watch them and they
bear you know and they if i say okay
well i interviewed abigail try about the
trans stuff oh that transphobe
well first of all i think that you would
say look maybe you don't
maybe you've never even seen michael
knowles maybe you think like certain
things about him but like
he's kind of a funny and smart guy take
a look like don't be afraid don't be
afraid okay michael now
uh uh don't be afraid to take a look and
i think that people
uh who who like refuse to who
hate without even investigation they're
just showing that they're scared right
they're showing that they're actually
scared of ideas or they're in curious
about ideas
or they feel you know protected in their
little teflon womb with everybody else
that's speaking
the way they are and we're all sometimes
guilty of that like you're around people
it's like yes yes we're we're right we
know this
um i think that the new york times
if they continue to only run and and let
me say the new york times still does
some of the most
incredible journalism around because
they have the resources too
but if they continue to just say no to
this idea
no to this word no to this person
writing any other story except about
that kind of person and how they live
they are not going to be incisive and
moving
and i think people will look other
places and one thing i just want to give
a pitch for which was i'm trying to do i
got a new little media
company what we're trying to do is like
yes things are terrible and we got to
push back but also let's just create
lots of new beauty right create
something new this beautiful like and
maybe it turns somebody's head
uh and you and you appeal to them in a
way like it it gets kind of um
we all get tired to listening to this
all the time right we
we want to fight it but you also just
want some new beauty
so that's like my pitch is like for new
beauty i won't ignore the other stuff
but i'm gonna try to create some stuff
over here nancy i love this point
i i like to this point is the essential
point to me
because i love complaining about these
things i love criticizing them i like
writing essays about what it means and
all the historical precedents
but ultimately what do i want what is my
vision for society what am i hoping for
i want good true beautiful
societies that's what i want and and it
i think sometimes we get so wrapped up
in debating what what can we read what
can we see
what can we watch that we don't have any
time to go see the beautiful painting
read the beautiful book in part because
these publishers are taking them away
from us
digital platforms are taking them away
as well but it's
this gets to this point of the argument
that i i always
try to come back to because i think it's
the reason we've lost i think is because
we're always debating in this abstract
we're always saying
this is about free speech versus
censorship and really i think
it's just about two sets of standards if
if you want to have this kind of culture
that i think broadly speaking we all
want
you need to articulate a vision for that
if you want more beautiful things
you got to build more beautiful things
and you've got to know what is beautiful
and you've got to know what is more
beautiful and what is less beautiful
and you've got to be able to articulate
that kind of a vision and i just think
especially on the right i say this as
the most knuckle-dragging conservative
on the panel
i think that the the right has has
basically seated that ground
because we're afraid of articulating
that kind of a vision but knows
give your guys a little credit because
look gina carano got booted from disney
right and what was that what
happened literally the next day the
daily wire announced that they were
going to be in production with her
that's what we're trying to do here i
mean this this is something i you know
how much it pains me to say nice things
about ben shapiro and jeremy boring but
uh but my pals here i mean they are
really doing the thing
and they said it they we've been talking
about it for years and they told me
about a year ago they said
we're doing it now we're not just going
to
comment on culture we're not just going
to criticize culture we are going to
make it
and damn it if they're going to stop us
we're going to press forward
yeah i think i think we have to do that
i think that's a great idea but we
shouldn't
also seed i mean when you have companies
with monopolistic power that can kick
people off for their viewpoint can erase
their books
uh i think they really should be treated
as dominant utilities under the law and
we should go after them
because this can't be allowed to stand
it can't be the
the culture of fear that will that is
already set in a setting in america
is is really something we should fight
against i wonder do you guys think that
perhaps the the hysteria or the over
correction or the yes we're taking out
dr
seuss it's like it's not just that
they're taking out dr seuss they're
going for books from literally 1937 1941
1947 it's like are we we're so tolerant
in 2021
that we take out books a hundred years
ago in the name of tolerance but do you
guys think that the over correction
might get some of the average people
to wake up like i think the average
person doesn't have a problem with mr
potato head i don't think the average
problem person
has a problem with aunt jemima and i
don't think the average person has a
problem
with dr seuss or uncle ben or the litany
of things that i could rattle off the
top of my head right now
nancy what do you think well first of
all i think you know what
culture changes ideas changes if they
want to get rid of uncle ben fine do it
they do whatever they want it's their
company um i frankly you know we're all
on twitter
we're all in the media we all have media
friends i think
85 90 of the country doesn't care about
this stuff at all at all
at all i mean
i know i'm not gonna predict what you're
gonna say but you're gonna say it
affects them even though they don't know
it
and that that is very true and that that
is a problem i agree with you aberdale
you know if you live in wherever and
you've never even heard of twitter or
these wars
but all of a sudden you go to get your
book that they heard of and they can't
they're going to say why and and that is
important
i mean it's a big deal because the
decisions that are being made are
top down just like you said it's not
coming from the american public my book
is not political book i didn't write a
political book
it's not a conservative book it's not a
liberal book and most of the support for
it
happens to be liberal but you won't get
access to those ideas
that's the thing and it's not coming
from the american public
it's top down from a bunch of monopolies
or mala
or companies from the monopolistic power
that's the problem
and they can virtue signal all they want
but what they're doing is they're
destroying
our access to ideas but what what the
left has done
very well here and i'm of course
referring to the sort of censorious
hard left what they've done very well is
they they learned from the 1960s there
was this famous phrase the long march
through the institutions
which came from this german radical rudy
deutsche who himself sort of took it
from the italian communist leader
antonio gramsci gramsci considered kind
of the founder of this
cultural movement uh rip up society
political correctness
and and what gramsci understood was the
reason that marxist revolution did not
happen is because conservatives had
the common sense and the left loses the
common sense when they do things like
ban dr
seuss now he gave a path forward and i
detail
this at length in my book speechless the
the path forward was the difference
between a war of position
and a war of maneuver war of maneuvers
you advance you go back you shoot shoot
shoot
a war of position is you you take the
institutions you infiltrate these
positions of power
and then you use them gradually and then
suddenly
to implement your cultural agenda it
would seem to me we're in the suddenly
phase of that now
this was a process that went on for
about a 100 years probably
70 years without anyone noticing and
then people started to notice
and and now they have so much
institutional power that i fear
we're entering into a kind of new normal
i fear we're entering into a period
where people will actually say
gosh darn it that dr seuss he was pretty
racist i sure am glad we got rid of
those books
because you know norms come from
normality you know how however long this
sort of thing persists
the likelihood that it remains in
perpetuity is
greatly increased well michael don't
worry about that because uh the
infallible fouchy told us that we can
get back to normalcy in a year or two so
you know upon him all right so i wanna i
wanna
allow you guys to all give a sort of uh
a positive
uh closing statement if you've got it
there's actually been a sort of theme
i think nancy you've been pushing it the
most that we just have to create is that
really just like at the end
if you're the average person watching
this you're not in that hysterical
sliver of people that seem to have all
the power
it's just create create look toward the
sunshine look toward the joy and one
positive thing my daughter i have a
young adult daughter and she
uh texted me the whole seuss thing
yesterday or two days ago and she's just
like oh
boy she is a young person that you would
think would be part of this clump
pushing for these things that we think
are crazy she's not she and her friends
are not so these young people exist too
yes for the young people abigail
i think you know we do have to create
our own institutions and institutions
for
for free thinking people not for left or
right for just people who are want to
discuss ideas in an open way where we
don't just label each other
and and i think we're starting to do
that um you know both with
locals and and with with daily wires
doing i mean you're seeing this
and and we just we just really need more
of it
you know look at this the liberals
saying nice things about you people
that's what we say i know this is a
wonderful thing this is what gives me
the most joy
is that i i agree with nancy and abigail
here and i think there's this other
thing which is people are waking up
to the craziness of the language you
know you hear this language from
the liberal left the tolerant liberal
left and they say
that we just want to expand the
curriculum we just want diversity and
inclusion and equity
and you realize that's not true they
just want to kick william shakespeare
out of the curriculum
they just want to exclu they want to
include some people
and exclude a lot of other people for
their beliefs that actually this is a
finite thing and they're just trying to
boot out all the things that we cherish
and like
and add their own extraordinarily
dangerous ideology to it i think people
are waking up to that
and they're finally willing to take more
of a cultural stance both pushing back
and as nancy points out quite
beautifully creating new
beautiful things all right well listen
all three of you are all stars in this
place so i thank you for doing this we
are going to link
to your books and upcoming books right
down below
and uh knowles i told you abigail might
be coming to my house for an illegal
party next week nancy if you want to hop
on a plane you're welcome but noel's
oh you can't you can't come anymore you
can't come holes i'm sorry i'm gonna be
there in the name of inclusion and
tolerance i want you to let me in when i
fly to l.a oh right
right because we need diversity of
thought when we do this thing
thank you guys it's been a pleasure have
a good weekend everybody thank you